I'm assuming you have all noticed that
our president has not been himself
lately
or maybe he's been more himself than
ever yes yes he danced but beyond that
President 44 has done more in the last 7
months in office than in the first seven
years with the stroke of a pen President
Obama cut short the prison sentences for
46 federal inmates across the country
today I can announce that the United
States has agreed to formally
re-establish diplomatic relations with
the Republic of Cuba today we're here to
announce America's clean power plan and
he knows he's killing it I actually
think I could win he's about as cocky as
a dentist from Minnesota before checking
his Yelp page why because Obama is in
his final lap he's final lap Obama slow
Bhama
he's high-fiving the fans and the
bleachers twerking in the end zone even
giving Iran a sportsman like pat on the
tush
nice work rouhani finally Obama is
showing up for America like an absent
dad who appears at a birthday party with
a pony that also plays catch what was a
deadbeat dad now huh cuz let's be real
up until now Obama has been a president
you wanted to like more than you did
just like the Mad Max sequel or chicken
and waffle lays not enough syrup
compared Obama to first term Obama who
backed off meaningful bank reform
expanded the war in Afghanistan and
treated torture allegations of bush
administration officials like indoor
doggie accidents what did you do oh yes
we can
ended up being yeah we could but I got a
thing flow Bhama on the other hand did
something first term Obama would never
do go to Kenya like a kid cannonballing
into a public pool watch me he even said
and of course on the first Kenyan
American to be President
States feel that it's the tingle of
Donald Trump's racist spidey-sense flow
Obama is almost better than campaign
Obama campaign Obama was the best
unabashed I will cut tux idealistic I
will restore and his views were still
evolving on gray Harwich get it gray gay
flow Obama almost makes you forget big
brobama who defended NSA spying programs
and went after journalists and
whistleblowers or covert ops bomber
complete with drones targeted
assassinations and terror Tuesday's slow
Bhama is hoping you forget all that
after all flow bomber threatened
Congress on the Iran deal I will veto
calls out Cosby that's right
majestically bursts into song little off
Obama takes no prisoners except the
hundred sixteen of them in a detention
center he still hasn't closed the clock
is ticking but don't think flow can't
finish the job
all he needs to do is close Guantanamo
Bay an assault rifles fist bump and
Snowden releases Kenyan birth
certificate to Gawker and peace the
out so ask your country about flow
bomber for the best
eighteen months your democracy will ever
have flew Obama does not protect against
secret trade deals or mass deportations
side effects may include exaggeration of
achievements and unrealistic
expectations for future presidents
unless that present in his Bernie
Sanders which could be a longshot sorry
just being honest keep hope alive
Bernie Sanders wants to become President
Clinton Bush Trump wife brother racist
uncle-in-law after one too many